jesse is with us in Los Angeles hi Jesse
how are you I'm doing good Dave how are
you doing better than I deserve
what's up thanks for taking my call and
my husband and I are wondering if we
should stay in the current rental
situation we are in or move to a new one
we are currently in baby step 2 ok
renting a short term it's camping until
you get your other goals hit right yes
so we want to pay the cheapest possible
that is reasonable for our family to
camp
absolutely so which one's more expensive
moving why would you move we're just
we're having some issues with the with
with the place that needs to be touched
and we are what our lease is up in a
couple weeks here and there's some water
damage that needs to be fixed and the
drywall needs to be patched and three
inspectors have been out to look at it
but no one's been hired to fix it and we
don't have a timeline on when the
drywall is going to be taken care of and
there has there's the inspectors or mold
inspectors and they said that it was
inconclusive everything's dry but there
are spores so we're just trying to
figure out you know if it's really
actually a safe place for us to stay and
try to navigate that and figure out how
to work with the property managers until
we're able to even find any lease okay
well number one is if you're not safe
you're moving yeah okay that's not
that's not an issue number two mold
spores can mean a lot of different
things I don't know whether you've got a
mold infested property here and your
family's not safer for whether there's
one corner that has three little spots
in it and somebody did a swab and found
some spores that will not make you sick
okay I mean really think about it it's
common yeah any more than walking in the
back
yard well if there's if you're growing
dandelions I mean you know I mean you'll
get hay fever sneeze too but it doesn't
it doesn't put you in the hospital but
your family's not safe if you have a
whole wall covered in the stuff okay and
so I don't know to what extent the mold
eradication has been done to what extent
needs to be done and what the timeline
is and so forth but it sounds to me like
you've got other issues and this mold
thing is just kind of brought it to the
surface no pun intended you know meaning
that you're just like kind of over these
property managers that are half but and
you don't like this house anyway yeah is
that right yes okay if you want to move
then then let's just move we don't have
to blame it on the mold unless the mold
is real and big enough it's a threat
okay okay so you can check on that
decide for yourself I mean but I think I
think now how many square inches of this
do you think you're dealing with I one
foot by one foot maybe three by three
feet see yeah that's a lot just kind of
but well that's where the water damage
is we weren't able to see the results
from the tests that were dying I'm
pretty substantial piece of damage
though neither you may have a problem
there that's not okay you know but I
mean I've had places where there was
something three inches by 3 inches and
people go bananas you know okay I just
don't want you to be that person but but
you know three feet by three feet that's
a bad gum leak that went on for a long
time well if yes I mean it's in a condo
and so the outside the roof has been
repaired it's the inside drywall that is
up to the owner to fix that hasn't been
so Olivera will the leak started in
mid-december and if the roof was fixed
about a month ago
okay all right well I think you guys
just have to decide two things number
one you don't have to move
up in rent you can move more laterally
in rent if you need to get out of there
for safety sake so whatever you're
paying now is your budget when you move
because you're trying to get out of debt
if you move every dollar you pay an
extra rent because of this emotional
situation causes you delay getting your
house someday and getting out of debt
someday right yes so we don't like we
want to limit that damage to your budget
that's what I'm after so either we're
going to fix this and feel comfortable
that your family's safe or you're going
to move something about the same price
or cheaper if you can find something
cheaper that kind of makes it a
no-brainer so then I guess what I would
do is I would I would get on the phone
with a property manager and say okay we
need some definite guidelines we are not
renewing a one-year lease and under
these circumstances we are going to
agree to give you 30 days to fix this if
it is fixed to our satisfaction during
that 30 days then we will renew if
you're willing to do that at all okay
but if you decide if they fix it right
and they fix it within 30 days and we
feel like our family's safe then that's
fine then just call the property manager
and go look you know I'm not you're not
going to have this done within 20 days
and so until you get this done it's not
fair for you to ask us to sign a
long-term lease because we need to know
that this property is going to be
repaired this has been going on for six
or eight months now mm-hmm and so you
know you need to give us an extension 30
days at a time and until you get it
repaired or until we run out of patience
with you getting it repaired if during
this 30 days you get it fixed to our
satisfaction and that mold is all
removed and eradicated and there's no
issue for our family's health we will
stay for one more year we will son lease
or you just make the decision to move
whichever one you want to I don't care
but don't move up and rent and then then
you just lay it out for the property
manager and say these are the terms
under which I will stay if you want me
to stay you're going to do this in a
reasonable timeline and you know to
expect them to have it all the work done
and you to be satisfied in 20 days
probably
Blee a lot to expect since it's been
going on six months so I'm going to give
them 30 days more but I'm not going to
sign a long-term lease during that time
until they prove out and say hey we're
going to take care of business here
we're going to do this properly and
sometimes folks in the property
management business just need a little
fire lit under them no pun intended
there either so hey thanks for the call
we appreciate you joining us hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]